in front of me is grigorevich Adso he is
a georgian politician he used to hold
the position of the Minister of Foreign
Affairs and because the casual in
leadership and now his presidential
candidate is representing their position
mr. Machado thank you for the interview
and welcome on the program thank you
very much
a very interesting fact about it is that
you for a number of years health dual
citizenship Russian and Georgian but you
renounced it in 2008
could you tell more why you decided to
give up here or Russian citizenship - no
I used to have one peso for just Russian
passport because I was I was I was
residing in Moscow and I had been
residing there from 1976 to 1993 and
when the Soviet Union collapsed in 1991
I was in the United States of America
don't remember for five or six months
and when I came back I discovered that
I'm a Russian citizen because Soviet
Union didn't exist then we returned back
to Georgia in 2004 and I got my Georgian
citizenship in 2005 for for anyway
four or five end of 2004 or beginning of
2005 and then after after after after
war russian-georgian war I said my
passport - comrade Medvedev and I said
that I'm renouncing my Russian
citizenship because I cannot tolerate
attitude of Kremlin toward
independence of my country of end of
Manish it took 11 months for Kremlin to
decide if they would like me I had to
sweep me off of my Russian citizenship
but eventually they did and then I am
now holder of general just one passport
of Georgian passport mr. Massad they're
gonna be the second front of their
presidential elections in Georgia and as
a result of their first round
you got around 38% of Waris support and
the difference between you and your
major opponent is very very significant
I am happy with the results
Dena this is official version of
so-called government and so-called
Georgian dream in reality I won the
first round
Bigler quite frankly I would not
speculate on how much actually what
percentage actually so-called Georgian
dream fixed at this election at this
elections but the most modest estimate
would be 15 percent something like this
because Salim is rubbish really
respectfully she's nobody
absolutely no but it's out of question
that's 38 percent of Georgians they
devote for her and if you if you just
imagine the amount of money spent by
so-called Georgian dream upon those
elections so we have unfortunately to
rely on the official data and I would
like to ask to analyze these data
because do you think it's a sign these
results which were quite unexpected for
the ruling party these results are are a
sign of your popularity and
Georgian citizens oh it's a sign of
general awareness of the ruling party
basically all of this combination of all
those reasons because when on July the
20th of this year eight of us eight of
us one of them is sitting next next to
me here eight of us jumped into two cars
and we started our 43,000 kilometer long
journey around Georgia and we said right
right the start that we're going to win
this election second is that everybody
knew knew me back from my five years as
the Minister for Foreign Affairs of
Georgia and they knew that I have done a
lot of things for this country that III
I designed and I brought to the
successful and campaign of
non-recognition of our occupied regions
fifty-eight states we've established
established diplomatic relations with
fifty-eight States we didn't have
diplomatic relations previously with I
have signed a lot of important treaties
for my country including visa
facilitation without that agreement with
the European Union against on their
opinion we couldn't be having reasonable
realization now and that can go on so
they know me in my reputation and the
third reason is that Georgian citizen is
outraged Georgian citizen is very angry
Georgian citizen hates Georgian a
so-called Georgian dream because
Georgian citizen has not been living so
bad since 2004 and they are not
accustomed to live and being submerged
into corruption crime economic
stagnation total absence of working
places 150,000 kids are living in hunger
dot port in hunger they are going to bed
hungry every third is unemployed in this
can
woman close to 1 million left this
country have has left this country since
2012 you're supported by former
president of Georgia Mikhail Saakashvili
he is one of your ardent supporters do
you think in the second round it's gonna
be an advantage or a disadvantage
everybody knows in Georgia at the time
absolutely independent I was independent
when I was a member of of the cabinet
from 2008 2012 I was not even a member
of the party I absolutely refused to to
enter enter and become the member of
this party because I had the extreme
amount of problems with with parties
internal polls and I've been expressing
that as what is with President
Saakashvili I will sum up my attitude to
him he is my friend as each and every
sounded rules in Georgian citizen I am
thankful to him that he has transformed
geographical geographical area into a
modern state he shall have a right to
live in Georgia so he shall get back his
Georgian citizenship if there are
questions which our law enforcing
agencies or our justice system has or
have excuse me to ask him he shall
answer those questions and if he is
going to have political future or not
that's up to Georgian nation to decide
that's if you become president he are
going to return his Georgian city I will
I'm going to party him sir yes I will
but I am NOT going to pardon only him I
am going to pardon all political
prisoners and please don't omit this
because some television channels in
Georgia they are cutting the second part
this phrase out I will of course you
will not I will pardon president circus
really I will pardon no political
prisoners I will pardon all women all
women who did not commit something
something beyond imagination and who
have kids outside outside prison I'm
going to do that extremely quickly in
maybe first two or three months not
maybe took first two or three months
because I know what's going on Prison is
a lawyer
HEIs a lawyer I want the justice to
prevail and justice shall prevail
because the third president of Georgia
shall have right to live here if if
you're gonna use this right or not it's
up to him again
it's up to him his political future is
up to Georgian people Georgian citizens
but to reside here is more housing
Corelli absolutely wee-wee off to him
that much you mentioned that you are
friends with Saakashvili but he's
absolutely remarkable because he
sometimes resorts to sharp criticism of
his former allies do you think that a
potential conflict between you and him
if you of course become president is a
workable scenario you know it is it is a
strange question because quite frankly I
am NOT I've never been choosing my
friends according to their political
beliefs
you both have political interests that's
what I yes is my friend and if evil if
there is a contradiction between my
beliefs and his beliefs I'll try my best
to retain our friendship but quite
possibly our political paths
part away I would not I would not start
screaming screaming like some of some of
his pre other friends - TV
correspondents that Misha Saakashvili is
the only one to be blamed for the
mistakes that Misha Saakashvili is
dictator Misha Saakashvili was an
obstacle when those guys were doing all
the job to transform Georgia to model
it's ridiculous he is not a dictator he
absolutely you will go which dictator
ever staged peaceful transition of power
mr. Machado you're absolutely right I
was your great example of a mistress
actually limb being a true Democrat that
he ensured peaceful transition of power
it's out of question and I think it's
one of the fundamental things for
Georgia to preserve this democratic
trendy tradition but his critics say
that when in power he was extremely
violent with his political opponents
that he put them in prison that were the
value Murray's violations of human
rights that was a demonstration peaceful
demonstration 2007 and he used some
methods to disseminate this
demonstration so nobody answer to this
criticism when we're speaking about
mistakes we shall differ mistakes from
dictatorship because Tosta if you would
like to remember 2007 yes it was a very
sad occasion in our history but again
nobody was this person that it is this
crowd incredibly large crowd in front of
the Parliament in the head
constitutional right
for for assembly they had constitutional
right to express their opinion and for
free speech I can tell you from my
standpoint a raid that raid which was
exercised against and inside T V MIDI
that was incredible mistake political
mistake incredible political mistake and
I think that in many ways it was the
beginning of the end in my answer about
Misha I could tell you tell you with
100% certainty that he is too young to
be written off but as each and every
person who actually did spend five or
six years in immigration
he will have to accustom to this country
from the scratch because this country
has said has changed significantly
what do you mean under our change is
Georgia as still a democracy it is it
has become more democratic as since
Saakashvili have left
no less democratic it it became less
democratic because if you if you check
those facts of election fixing if you if
you go through our TV market and
discover that there is only basically
one important independent TV station
Rasta with you if you go through
Internet
Internet Information hubs and you'll
discover that basically nearly 99% of
them are controlled by so-called
Georgian dream by Evan is really through
all this
of course it's less democratic but the
major freedoms are here we we haven't
and even is really with his so-called
Georgian dream is chicken pox too now it
is chicken pox v3 entre v3 angka the
pathologist believed he would be
banished and after three first three
days you are having temperatures over 40
or 41 and then after three days after
three days you are quickly recovering so
we are having it even is really is a
chicken pox mr. Machado returning to the
presidential elections according to
their current Georgian Constitution the
role of the president is quite symbolic
so it has effectively no executive
powers why are these elections important
for you personally and for the country
yes you you would like to ask me why
these elections were so heated it seems
it's very very correct and timely answer
because it's know not only presidential
elections but also and most importantly
it's referring them on the future of our
country everybody understands that when
we are winning not if when we are
winning those elections we're winning
the referendum on our country and we are
bringing closer snap parliamentary
elections everybody understands that too
second it's utter nonsense that
president of Georgia is not going to
have enough power to excuse me Supreme
Commander of of Armed Forces but as far
as I know it's a good point but as far
as I know you cannot execute even this
function without the consent of the
Aleutians cardinally
used to say patience okay
Supreme Commander the the chief
representative of country in
international relations power of veto
power to approve Prime Minister and
power of pardon and a lot of other but
more support and don't forget please
there is a spirit of Constitution and
there is a letter of constitution spirit
of Constitution means political process
and nobody can curb me to be head of the
political process I can see any
government not only is of so-called
Georgian dream but any government when I
ask 50 or 100,000 my citizens to go out
in the street and join my protest for
something who is going to curb that
right and just imagine yourself what
kind of demonstration we are going to
stage so so-called Georgian dream is
very very right when they are fighting a
deadly fight for this post but they lost
that fight you mentioned a very
interesting fact that you think that
these are not just presidential
elections this is a referendum about the
future of the country now in the second
front you and your opponent
mrs. rubbish really are left if we do
not focus on who supports whom you're
supported by Mikhail Saakashvili and his
political party whereas rubbish really
is supported by even Israeli and
Georgian dream what are their
ideological differences between you and
your opponent I think that you agree on
the Western pair for the European path
for Georgio on NATO accession I am
supported by I am supported trust me by
well over 40 percent of Georgian
citizens this is the most important
thing for me when it comes to
differences I will tell you what I did
so-called Georgian dream and their
candidate compañero
the rubbish really they think that
everything is wonderful in Georgia they
think that the economic situation she
just said that that economic situation
is not that bad as you're describing it
top to me to to to to though the
instructor journalists even issue the
things that everything was perfect I
mean for five years he gave a paradise
to Georgian citizen and then suddenly
suddenly he jumped out and said that I
just discovered that 1 million are
living in poverty when everybody got
those outrageous reports from World Bank
the United Nations and UNICEF they are
scared to death because they understand
Georgian citizens are deprived of all
achievements economic achievements which
which the government gave to them from
2004 to 2012 country is submerging into
extreme poverty this is the difference
we are screaming that we shall abolish
in our budget all the luxuries all those
stupid expenses which are made just to
win elections financing all these all
these soccer programs and I don't know
baseball team and Georgia an ice hockey
tip you can you imagine the idiocy of of
this where Ukrainian and Bulgarian
hockey players are playing in the fourth
or fifth league I do not remember where
and we shall canalize all these money to
health care to social assistance to
education and to defence otherwise we
are going to disappear as a nation our
demography is cut catastrophic that's
what we differ on and those excuse me my
Georgia and those idiots are proposing
to this country marijuana plantations is
the locomotion for our economy in the
21st century in an epoch of a knowledge
economy economy of knowledge when when
we shall jump on the train which is
going to the 22nd century otherwise we
are going to church you to become for
forever losers they are calling our
civil society or non-governmental
organizations fascists
those idiots do not even know meaning of
this world I don't know who is doing
this I know but he said that it was not
a correct word - it was not it was the
wrong thing to do that's what I want no
but he said what he is thinking I don't
care about his excuses and his patterns
I do not because they said that they are
going to bank or position on the head
they speak of Speaker of Parliament they
have this Clockwork Orange you know as a
Speaker of Parliament who said that he
is going to bank opposition on the head
I'm very happy that he got bang on the
head after the first tour you have
another imagine different I I don't I
want to talk about your a difference
difference with Ivanishvili but we're
talking with your opponent and it's of
course your absolutely different
backgrounds you have a lot in common
because I misses or obese really he used
to hold the position of the Minister of
Foreign Affairs under also Saakashvili
leadership she was before you but she
the French career diplomat she was born
in France and us-soviet
career diplomat they have problems with
this I do not have any problems with
that because because a person was born
in Bern in born excuse me in in 1958 in
Tbilisi he couldn't be anything else so
I I was also a diplomat and I can tell
tell you I am very proud of it because I
participated in
Oshie ations which made our life safer
prohibition of chemical weapons and
profit prohibition of nuclear tests and
I went through a fantastic school and I
don't know I don't know what have
professional qualifications of the
rubbish really but excuse me you but I
shall repeat this words but when people
are saying industry that I am the best
Minister for Foreign Affairs in our
history are very proud of it
so called Georgian dream and even
Israelis TV stations they try to play on
this the time a KGB agent Russian see
Russia see Lewis agent I'm this I'm that
didn't work at all if you win the
elections so what reaction on the part
of the Russian government do you expect
I spent five years of my life fighting
with with Russia and I succeeded and
left Russia in a shameful company of
Venezuela Syria Nicaragua in our oh no
I'm not the future of the occupied
territories no no because because I
don't know what the reaction of Kremlin
is going to be I mean we are speaking
about your country your Russian is the
giorgia by its her independence took
strategic role away from Russia in South
in Caucasus and Russia is fighting to
return that back but trouble is that to
occupied regions they are not solving
Russian problem at all
they are suitcases without a handle
no you can throw them away because it's
a shame you cannot keep them because you
do not need it you're just wasting your
money upon that this is what's happening
I don't know what a criminal reaction is
going to be and quite frankly I don't
care who is your role model among
present or past world leaders George
Marshall and why because this is the man
who won the Second World War
don't believe that Soviet Union could
win this war without the United States
military and logistical assistance you
are you are young and they will be
telling to you that we could win this
war alone forget about it yes I would
like to thank you for the interview and
for your time thank you very much it was
pleasure to be with you